Gluten e leite, sua opinião, doutor?
Inflamatório para todo mundo? Olá,
pessoal. Tudo bem com vocês? Hoje vamos
bater uns papo super importante sobre
dois alimentos que geram muita polêmica,
o glúten e o leite. Sabe aquela história
de que todo mundo deveria cortar esses
dois da dieta porque são inflamatórios e
muita gente contesta isso? Pois é, eu
vou contar para vocês o que que a
ciência mais recente tem a dizer sobre
isso. E olha, prepara-se, porque tem
muita coisa interessante para
compartilhar. Primeiro, deixa eu contar
uma história fascinante. Existe um
médico italiano chamado Alécio Façano.
Esse cara é o Fera, tá? Ele é o diretor
do Centro de Pesquisas de Doença Celica
lá em Harvard. Imagina só. E sabe o que
que ele descobriu? Uma proteína chamada
zonulina. Gente, isso foi
revolucionário. A zonulina é tipo um
porteiro no nosso intestino. Ela decide
quando abrir ou fechar as portinhas
entre as células intestinais, as famosas
tight junctions ou junções estreitas. E
aí vem o pulo do gato. Quando a gente
come glúten, mais especificamente uma
fração dele chamado gliadina, o nosso
intestino libera zonurina. E aí, meu
amigo, essas portinhas se abrem. que
isso acontece com todo mundo, não é só
com quem tem doença celica, não. O Dr.
Fazano mostrou isso em estudos com
tecidos intestinais humanos.
Impressionante, não é? Mas calma lá,
deixa eu explicar uma coisa super
importante. É verdade que o glúten abre
essas junções intestinais em todos nós,
mas e esse mais é relativo, nem todo
mundo desenvolve a mesma resposta
inflamatória por causa disso. Sabe por
quê? Porque boa parte das pessoas tem um
sistema de compensação que dá conta
disso. É como se o corpo falasse:
"Beleza, abriu a portinha, mas já vou
fechar rapidinho aqui." Em questão de
minutos, tudo pode voltar ao normal. O
problema acontece quando a pessoa já
está inflamada ou estressada, quase
ninguém, né mesmo? Ou tem predisposição
genética. Aí sim a coisa complica.
Nesses casos, as portinhas ficam abertas
por mais tempo, entram substâncias que
não deveria entrar e o sistema imune
fica doido, criando uma bagunça danada
lá dentro, podendo gerar inclusive
doenças autoimunes.
Agora vamos falar do leite, que também é
um tema quente, né? Quantas vezes você
já ouviu alguém dizer, eu mesmo já disse
muitas vezes, que leite é inflamatório e
que ninguém deveria tomar. Pois é, esse
é um tema polêmico, tem pesquisas
recentes, incluindo várias revisões
sistemáticas, que são estudos do mais
alto nível científico, mostrando que o
leite não é inflamatório, talvez pra
maioria das pessoas. Porém, os pacientes
que chegam até mim geralmente estão
inflamados, estão estressados. E para
esse tipo de paciente, sem dúvida, é
muito prudente cortar tanto glúten
quanto o leite. Na grande maioria das
vezes, essas retiradas de alimentos
contribuem muito pra melhora. Vários
deles conseguem também retomar algum
desses alimentos, glúten e leite, após a
melhora clínica. Então, vamos falar do
contraditório. Em 2019 foi publicada uma
mega revisão na revista Advances e
Nutrition, que analisou vários ensaios
clínicos randomizados. E sabe o que que
descobriram? Que o consumo de leite
derivados não só não aumentava os
marcadores inflamatórios, como em alguns
casos tinha efeito anti-inflamatório,
principalmente pessoas com síndrome
metabólica. Olha que coisa, né? O grande
problema é que o leite é um alimento
muito complexo. Ele contém muitas
substâncias diferentes misturadas.
Algumas são muito boas e outras que
podem ser prejudiciais. É isso que
complica esses estudos nutricionais. E
tem mais, os laticínios fermentados,
tipo iogurte, kefir, são muito melhores
nesse quesito. Eles contêm substâncias
bioativas, palavrinha chique para dizer
que são componentes que fazem bem pra
gente, como é o caso da lactoferrina,
que é praticamente um remédio, tem
propriedades antiinflamatórias bem
comprovadas. A lactoferrina é tão
poderosa que consegue inibir citocinas
pró-inflamatórias como fator de necrose
tumoral alfa e ainda estimula a produção
de terleucina 10 que é uma interleucina
antiinflamatória. É ou não é incrível
como a natureza trabalha? Claro que
casos e casos, né, gente? Pra grande
maioria dos meus pacientes, há um grande
benefício em parar, nem que seja
temporariamente o glúten o leite. Mas
veja bem, isso é diferente dizer que o
leite é inflamatório para todo mundo.
Temos os casos da intolerância não
selica ao glúten, os casos de alergia à
proteína do leite e a famosa
intolerância à lactose. Em todos esses
casos, o leite sim pode causar
inflamação e sintomas bem desagradáveis.
E aí que entra a beleza da medicina
funcional e de estilo de vida. Não
existe essa história de que tudo se
resolve igual para todo mundo, né? One
size fits all, tamanho único para todo
mundo. Cada pessoa é única com sua
genética, seu microbioma intestinal, seu
histórico de saúde, o que funciona pro
seu vizinho pode não funcionar para você
e tá tudo bem. Na minha prática clínica,
eu sempre faço uma avaliação
personalizada. Olhamos biomarcadores
inflamatórios como proteína C reativa,
como outros marcadores, avaliamos
sintomas clínicos histórico familiar e
aí sim decidimos qual que é a melhor
estratégia. Às vezes fazemos teste de
eliminação e reintrodução para ver como
é que o corpo responde. É um trabalho de
detetive mesmo. Tem gente que se
beneficia muito de uma dieta sem glúten,
mesmo sem ter doença silíica. Outras
pessoas comem pão todo dia e estão
aparentemente ótimas. Algumas melhoram
tirando o leite comum e usando o leite
casina A2A2 que tem uma proteína
diferente e costuma ser muito mais bem
tolerado.
Outras tomam leite integral no café da
manhã e não tem problema nenhum. O
importante é você conhecer o seu corpo,
prestar atenção nos sinais que ele dá.
Se você come glúten, e fica com a
barriga inchada, gás, dor de cabeça em
cansaço, pode ser que vale a pena fazer
um teste de retirada de glúten por 30
dias e ver como é que você se sente.
Geralmente funciona bem, mas não precisa
entrar em pânico achando que o glúten
está destruindo o seu organismo se você
não tem sintoma nenhum. E olha que
interessante, estudos recentes 2024,
2025 continuam confirmando essas
descobertas. A ciência tá evoluindo e
hoje entendemos que a inflamação é um
processo muito mais complexo do que
simplesmente demonizar um alimento ou
levantar outro às alturas. É
simplesmente diferente falar: "Esse
alimento simplesmente inflama e aquele
simplesmente não inflama". Depende da
dose, da frequência, da qualidade do
alimento, do estado do seu intestino, do
seu sono, do seu estress. Tá tudo
interconectado.
Por isso que eu sempre digo, antes de
sair cortando tudo da sua dieta baseado
que você leu na internet, continue
lendo, continue se informando, mas
cuidado. Procure um profissional
qualificado em medicina funcional. Faça
exames, avalie os seus sintomas, entenda
o que seu corpo precisa. Pode ser que
você descubra que o problema nem é o
glút e o leite, mas sim a qualidade
desses alimentos ou algum outro alimento
que parecia ser inocente ou ainda
combinação com outros fatores de estilo
de vida. Resumindo a ópera, o glúten
realmente aumenta a permeabilidade
intestinal em todos nós. Foi provado
pelo estudo do Dr. Fazano através da
zonulina, mas não são todos que
desenvolvem inflamação significativa por
causa disso. O leite, por sua vez, na
forma industrializada e não fermentada,
pode ser inflamatório pra maioria das
pessoas, mas pode até ter efeitos
anti-inflamatórios na forma orgânica e
fermentada. A chave é a personalização e
o autoconhecimento. Então, da próxima
vez que alguém falar para você que tem
que cortar glúo em leite porque são
inflamatórios para todo mundo, você já
sabe, a ciência mostra que não é o caso
para todo mundo. Cada caso é um caso. O
que importa é como seu corpo responde a
esses alimentos.
Eu espero que essa conversa tenha
ajudado, tenha esclarecido muitas
dúvidas. Eu sei que eu posso ter falado
em alguns momentos coisas
contraditórias, mas tente rever o vídeo
e tente analisar o tudo que eu falei
aqui. Lembre-se, informação de qualidade
é poder e conhecer o seu corpo é o
primeiro passo para uma vida mais
saudável e equilibrada. Um abraço e até
a próxima.
Compartilhe os vídeos, faça bem. A vida
de alguém pode mudar também no canal do
Doutor, além do se envolva. Ah.